barricades and Rubble destroyed property
and homes parts of the Janine refugee
camp resemble nothing less than a war
zone life here was hard long before the
hamus attacks in Israel on October the
7th before the war on Gaza
began because the camp has long been a
Bastion for armed Palestinian resistance
groups but the frequent raids by the
Israeli Army have since become a
terrifying nightly ordeal for people
like NAD Nim
and her young
family we Tred to find the furthest
safest Corner in the house to hide in
the sound of the explosions is
terrifying I've had to take her to the
hospital twice because she went into
shock it's the same for all families
we're struggling to cope pools of blood
Mark a place of
death at least one person was killed
here by what people say was an Israeli
drone attack only hours before the
Israeli Army released this video which
we understand shows the actual
strike the destruction you see here or
in Gaza the people fleeing their homes
the fear everyone is afraid for their
children for their neighbors for their
friends of course anger is rising and to
the point of explosion the graffiti
describes the dead as Martyrs walls
adorned with posters and photographs of
some of those killed in recent weeks
months years some are shockingly young
but they are prepared to die fighting a
powerful Army to end Decades of an
occupation that breaks international
law an Israeli military bulldozer did
this dug its blade into the tarmac and
ripped up a road along which people live
Collective punishment say rights groups
and those who live
here they storm the camp all the time
they arrest people they destroy they
terrorize people to try and force them
to flee there are barricades like this
one right the way across the refugee
camp here in Janine at night people move
them into the center of the road to try
and stop Israeli forces from entering
people here are very afraid indeed and
many of the people that live down that
Alleyway have left in the last couple of
days children play at a window opposite
the bombed out mosque where Israel says
gunman hid
hnia Zan lives close by as she has done
for more than 50
years many people have fled my
one-year-old nephew was eating by the
window there was an explosion the glass
covered him the soldiers demolish homes
they break inside they beat people as
the mass killing of civilians in Gaza
continues Palestinians here too suffer
the violence of what they say is Israeli
Army Revenge
Charles staford Al jazer Janine refugee
camp in the occupied West
Bank make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz